this is the home of democracy in the U.S
the Capitol building where men and women
represent what the Constitution refers
to As We the People democracy in the
United States is under attack both
Democrats and Republicans see it and
both say that they are the ones
defending it we are the ones trying to
save our democracy very simple
very soon danger to democracy comes from
the radical left not from the right
[Music]
Stand By and Watch the most fundamental
freedom in this country the freedom to
vote
and have your vote counted
and be taken from you and the American
people look
as your president I will defend our
democracy with every fiber of my being
and I'm asking every American to join me
on the surface Joe Biden's Democrats and
the Trump Camp of Republicans may be
going into these elections to contest
for seats here in Congress behind me but
this video will show that the upcoming
midterm elections are truly a referendum
on Democracy with grave consequences for
the United States and Beyond
we'll look at how Donald Trump is trying
to take control of America's election
system how he and his Camp have revised
and expanded plans to influence election
results and how this cause is attracting
candidates who feel legitimized not by
voters but by a higher power
God is with us he has chosen me
and he has chosen you
[Music]
and we'll hear from poll workers who are
getting ready to defend U.S democracy
it really Cuts right into the heart of
the foundation of this country
foreign
the 2020 attack on U.S democracy peaked
right here
this was rhetoric turned into action
Trump's supporters tried but failed to
stop Joe Biden rightfully being declared
President those hours of physical attack
at the heart of America's democracy were
a terrible shock to the nation
well what happened here is still under
investigation the power struggle has
moved on it's all about sowing doubt in
the election system if enough people
repeat a lie enough times it begins to
stick and Donald Trump makes sure that
the legend of the big steel stays alive
in a recent post on his truth social
network Trump still demands to be
declared the rightful president he calls
for a new election to be held
immediately as a quote minimal solution
this is the first time in U.S history
that a sitting president refused to
accept election defeat and that's
despite some 50 lawsuits on the claims
of election fraud
so what actually happened to all those
cases even if the Trump campaign
complained that it did not have its day
in court there have been post-election
reviews in each of the six Battleground
states that could have made a difference
and in each one of those instances there
was no credible evidence of fraud
produced by the Trump campaign or his
supporters
in fact top Republican attorneys were so
worried about Trump's election denial
that they conducted their own
investigation
their report concluded that the
elections were lost not stolen morning
fellow Republicans that if the American
people lose trust that our elections are
free and fair we will lose our democracy
but Trump's Camp still makes these
unfounded claims about the elections
sowing doubt about the well-established
fact that there simply was no evidence
of fraud has become a campaign strategy
and it's well on the way to becoming a
mainstream narrative in the Republican
camp
at this Republican fundraiser in Miami
top conservatives meet to talk strategy
and campaign funding the fraud narrative
is on everybody's lips
Blake Masters is working the room the
Republicans rising star from Arizona is
running for Senate he has Donald Trump's
backing but that comes at a price he has
to stick with the big steel narrative
this shouldn't be a partisan issue
everybody should want free and fair
elections where it's transparent where
you have bipartisan poll workers poll
observers making sure there's no
Shenanigans so who got elected in the
last presidential election Joe Biden's
in the White House and unfortunately
we're all suffering because of that few
here are concerned with the question of
evidence that includes Trump's greatest
rival within the Republican Party
welcome America's governor the 46th
governor of Florida and future president
of the United States Ryan DeSantis
the Republicans new strongman may want
to challenge Trump but he too feeds the
stolen election narrative thank you so
much please please take your seat it was
corrupt as hell and the State of Florida
if you do that here you're going to jail
for it so we're not going to put up with
it
many people here are convinced by the
election fraud story even though Florida
investigations found no evidence to back
it up
why if everyone is is talking about and
there is a lot of uh evidence
the court why they don't want to take
that in in evidence why they don't want
to make a case
they they probably they're afraid of the
establishment I do believe that there is
there's massive amounts of voter fraud
I believe that President Trump should
have won the presidency
the picture Trump and a large part of
the Republicans have painted of a
corrupted American democracy is starting
to stick it's a fresco I developed a
technique myself to get stucco to stick
to a canvas and then I painted it while
it was wet and uh you know just like him
it's a Timeless classic of a style
and uh it's beautiful and the colors
represent you know Trump loves gold
Donald Trump has also expanded his
technique he's not only backing election
deniers for Congress and spreading the
LIE among voters he's specifically
focusing on helping loyalists become
election officials who make local
decisions about results the election
from right now the fight for democracy
here in the United States is all about
the election system arguably democracy
dies unless voters can be sure that
their vote will be counted accurately
and as poll workers in the highly
contested state of Pennsylvania here
prepare for the upcoming midterms former
U.S president Donald Trump still denies
that he ever lost an election
vice president Mike Pence was the man
who made that loss official when he
certified the national results in 2020
he could only do that because officials
in every state had done the same in
their region despite pressure from the
White House Joseph R Biden Jr of the
state of Delaware has received 306 votes
Donald J Trump of the State of Florida
has received 232 votes Georgia's
Republican Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger famously stood his ground
when President Donald Trump personally
called to tell him the numbers he wanted
to see certified and to tell him that he
had won we don't agree that you have one
we don't I didn't agree about the 200
000 number that you mentioned we have
all the votes we need you know we wanted
to say if you took these are the most
minimal numbers the numbers that I gave
you those are numbers that are certified
your absentee ballot sent to vacant
addresses your your out-of-state voters
four thousand nine twenty five you know
when you add them up it's many more time
it's many times the 11
779 number
[Music]
having failed to change the Secretary of
State's Minds in 2020 Trump started
focusing on changing the secretaries of
State the six Battleground states where
Trump alleged election fraud in 2020 are
among the 27 states where the
Republicans are sending election deniers
into races for key positions this year
if elected they will be in place to
approve or reject the results of the
next presidential elections in 2024.
let's look at Arizona Mark fincham is
the Republican candidate for Secretary
of State there fincham a declared
election denier criticized vice
president Mike Pence for calling in the
National Guard on January 6th
[Music]
over an existing president he was not
enough if elected fincham would be in
charge of organizing the next
presidential election in Arizona in that
he would be working with the governor
Trump's favorite for that position also
managed to secure the Republican
candidacy one of the hardest
politicians in this world I think at
this moment that I think it's going to
be that way for a long time she's
incredible
Gary we'll start with you
you've called Joe Biden an illegitimate
president what does that mean he lost
the election and he shouldn't be in the
white house we had a corrupt election
I'd actually like to ask everybody on
this stage if they would agree we had a
corrupt stolen election raise your hand
[Music]
lake has repeatedly made it clear that
she won't take another election no to
Trump for an answer calling on her
followers to defend what she says is the
almighty's choice for governor this
fight before us proves to us that God is
with us he has chosen me and he has
chosen you
and I don't believe for one second that
God makes mistakes
and a third election denier is running
to become Arizona's attorney general
Arizona could end up with election
deniers overseeing certifying and
potentially challenging election results
in time for the next presidential
elections
that's the strategy that Trump Camp has
put in place across the country we have
people who hate our country running our
government Jim is a winner he's
incredible
this matters for the next presidential
elections but also for countless local
races in the U.S elections are held at
every level of society not just
politicians also many judges County
clerks and top law enforcement officials
like sheriffs are elected so destroying
trust in the process that goes into
selecting them also damages trust in the
courts and police
[Music]
this is downtown Philadelphia and the
city's convention center right here
there's music playing people are walking
about everything is back to normal but
two years ago during the presidential
elections it was the postal ballots
counted in the hall behind me that led
to tumultuous scenes outside hundreds of
trump supporters showed up calling for
an end to the count and the poll workers
who were accused of manipulation back
then also intimidated and threatened
already asking themselves how bad things
will get this time
we're at the election commissioner's
Warehouse on the outskirts of town this
time the count will take place here
mostly for security reasons
it's been very it's been a very
difficult time for me personally uh just
regard with regard to how I live my life
my circle's a lot smaller and I take
more Care and More caution uh when I
decide where I'm going and what I'm
going to do you know certainly
my mom for example and I was proud her
about her daughter as the chairwoman of
Philadelphia Board of Elections people
ask her what her daughter does for a
living she says she works for the city
on Election night these machines will
count postal ballots observers from all
parties will be able to watch from just
a few feet away it's the same setup as
last time but last time it wasn't enough
to convince the demonstrators outside
Detroit saw similar scenes yet here too
the top election official has stayed on
despite threats and intimidation
personally I had to file for and take
classes for a gun license so that I can
carry because I was approached uh
leaving my home going for a walk
um and uh
it's just made it's really saddened me
that people uh uh take
democracy and their right to vote so
lightly that they
are willing enough to put out lies you
know family feels like you know what
Janice you need to let this go uh you
know it's not worth it
um and you know friends and loved ones
have a tendency to say that but then
there are colleagues that I work with
um that say things like well if you quit
they win and
um we don't want them to win
American democracy has passed its stress
test for now Donald Trump failed to
overturn the 2020 presidential elections
there are checks and balances to this
thing even if your secretary say even if
you're president of the United States as
we saw in Donald Trump you can't
overthrow our uh our democracy because
um it's too important to us as a uh as
citizens of the United States but now he
and his strategists are trying to so
distrust in the election process
effectively turning skeptical Americans
into weapons against their own democracy
foreign
Trump's Target is the U.S but any impact
he makes would also be a blow to
democracies around the world and those
are already Under Pressure the
Assumption at the end of the Cold War
that democracy would continue to spread
proved wrong today democracy is backed
down to 1989 levels
and the flip side of that is over the
past 10 years alone the proportion of
people living in autocracies has jumped
from just under half to 70 percent
it's not only Trump and and and the way
he's taking the Republican party and
with the evangelicals and so on Orban in
Hungary became this nationalist
reactionary and and suddenly Christian
um Elias with that you have erdogan in
Turkey Muslim reactionary nationalist
you have Modi in India with a Hindu
nationalist that it's reactionary so
it's not only the United States but
naturally being a major power a
superpower in the world
the weight of the United States is is is
is enormous
[Music]
democracy puts the power in the hands of
the people attempts are underway to
undermine trust in that process
some Trump Republicans are even
preparing to reject election results
that don't hand them more power these
midterm elections are seeing the next
attack on American democracy the biggest
stress test yet will be the upcoming
presidential elections in 2024. in a
world increasingly tipping towards
autocracy whether American democracy
remains strong will have an impact on
everybody's chances around the world to
live in a Land of the Free
[Music]